Oliver wrote in hey guys what was the
time you did something really
embarrassing and nobody noticed I have
slipped on ice and fallen many times
sometimes people have noticed and
sometimes people haven't and if you can
imagine you know that cartoonish thing
where you slip and papers just go
everywhere around you like a banana
banana peel like slipping on a banana
peel I've had a couple Falls like that
which fortunately I was young enough
where I think if that happened now I
would probably be more seriously injured
but when you're like 16 and you fall
it's not nearly as big of a deal as when
you're an adult so I've had a couple of
those I've definitely had situations
where I've been on like my Bluetooth
phone when I'm driving around so I'm not
physically holding my phone and I'm
having a very animated conversation and
then I noticed that someone next to me
is looking over and I must look
completely nuts because I'm having a
very animated conversation in my car
although people know about Bluetooth
right clearly I was attracting attention
by what I was doing where people were
looking at me like I was doing something
really really odd and listen how many
times have I embarrassed myself on the
David Pakman show which are now part of
the public record and on YouTube for all
to see the most embarrassing things I've
done and nobody noticed I guess are the
times where I do a story that I should
be embarrassed by and people don't
notice although I guess it doesn't
happen that up and I don't know have an
entire archive I mean just last week you
meant to say Mitch McConnell of another
big leader of the Republicans in the
Senate and he said [ __ ] McConnell I
mean yeah I was personally offended do
you have any times where you did
something very embarrassing and nobody
noticed yeah well I don't think anyone
noticed so I had to make a two-hour
drive which I was really not prepared
for I should have probably went to the
bathroom before this yeah needless to
say I had to go about an hour and a half
into the trip and okay talk and
deadlocks traffic there was no sign of
me getting out of that anytime soon
right so I had to make do with what I
had and what I had was a normal sized
plastic water bottle maybe around this
size okay so while driving we're kind of
stopped though because it's deadlocked
traffic I urinated into the bottle but
the bottle is not big enough so I had to
dump the bottle of urine out the window
and go at it again okay I think too
times was enough but yeah it was pretty
bad
it was pretty bad I think that you don't
have to worry about any other scandal
you've ever had on the show right now
yeah I mean I think all of Joe Tories
are pretty bad I think all of those
scandals Keurig eight and what are the I
don't even listen I can't even remember
the other scandals now they've little
named controversy no main controversy on
earth or cat gate the entire thing I'm
having trouble even remembering why we
cared about those given this news story
that that you've told okay that does it
for today major bonus show today tune in
how do you get the bonus show it's very
easy you sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership once you
sign up that's it then you can get the
bonus show